you know what helps heal
oh ice cream cool baby let me just tell
you
you're super excited about this
oh my gosh we're going to do a vogue
real quick okay let's do it okay
okay stand oh we're going to let's bring
this in after let's let's pretend we
didn't do this okay he's out of frame
okay
today marks the return of blue bell ice
cream to the vegas alley yeah the ice
cream company stopped by the station to
deliver some sweet treats and smiles to
our employees blue bell's distribution
center is located in henderson and can
be found uh the blue bell ice cream can
be found again at your smiths and
albertson stores that which is so
exciting because
for those of you who are from the south
you know that blue bell is the bomb does
anybody say that anymore no okay what
should i say
um
it's the what
it's lit it's lit blue bell is lit kids
um
but no so everybody was so excited i
think it was 2015 when they opened the
distribution center and then they ran
into the problems and they shut down the
distribution center in 2016 so we've
been without now we've been deprived
it's bad and i've lost 20 pounds and so
i'm ready to put it back on because
google is back baby so i'm trying their
peach brand new flavor and it is split
oh and i got my for real one of my
favorites is mint chocolate chip i'm
sorry for that sound on there that's
that's right here yeah mint chocolate
chip is phenomenal and you said it's
actually controversial in some sectors
so mint chocolate chip is is my favorite
ice cream flavor ever yeah and i get
made fun of that all the time people say
that that's like eating toothpaste
flavored ice cream they have not had
bluebell
mint chocolate chip it is the best ice
cream ever i love this ice cream but i
have to say peaches is quickly becoming
my new favorite this is fantastic
there are chunks of peach in there real
chunks of peach
so good and bluebell vanilla is the best
vanilla
probably in the world and we're not
getting paid for this although you can
bell if you want to hire us yeah we're
here no i really do love uh that they're
back and i'm excited to see that back in
stores especially around christmas when
they have peppermint ice cream oh my god
that's my absolute birthday cake they're
dutch chocolate there's so many great
flavors so welcome back to las vegas
blue belt we are super happy to have you
all right
are you ready i'm ready explaining oh
yeah i'm always ready for last time
coming up in today's while explaining
one country artist is